want to know what's heating up theaters  this weekend I have no more family in  the foreigner a grieving businessman  seeks justice after his daughter is  killed in a terrorist attack you have no  idea who you're dealing with yes I do  do you in happy deathday  a college student is forced to relive  the last 24 hours of her life to find  her killer freedoms even have to fight  for a future Supreme Court justice  helped to define his career by defending  an innocent man in Marshall the only way  to get through a biggest duel was to  break it down see what's hot in theaters  with this week's fantasy patient so  what's your weekend ticket going to be  let us know by commenting see you next  time on weekend ticket  [Music]